but you know um I saw this on Twitter
and and Twitter really does spark a lot
of my thoughts and it really does spark
a lot of the topics that I pick for this
show so you know yesterday I I was being
a little silly guys you know me I just I
got jokes sometimes so I was tweeting
and if you don't follow my Twitter you
should follow pearly things with a z and
I just decided to tweet some basic
things that my mother told me growing up
um and you know this is wisdom that we
conventionally got from our grandmothers
our great grandmothers um our fathers
but for some reason in modern society
everything has just been lost I really
don't get
it um so I tweeted men don't generally
like fat chicks so I've been getting a
lot of heat for not bringing up the
exception to the rule so I was like you
know what I am today I'm feeling so kind
I'll even add it generally I won't put
men don't like fat chicks I'll put men
generally don't like fat chicks or men
don't generally like fat chicks and you
know I know there's exceptions there's
the chubby chasers but that doesn't make
it the rule and um what what do we get
do we get women saying I agree with you
this is such a great point you know the
men come in you know and they'll say
correct again now we have Prince Carlton
say what's fat we definitely like curvy
though all right Prince
Carlton I need you to stop gaslighting
us what you guys like all right is the
you know the hourglass
figure you know maybe maybe a big butt
right big boobs but the waist is always
skinny you got we know you don't like
guts and we can look at this because we
look at the most richest most handsome
most successful men and you know we
don't see them with fatties we don't
even see them with chubby chicks so you
know I I don't I we don't as men guys
please stop arguing the exception yes
there are some fat chicks that have good
figures but they're not the rule most
women are kind of shaped like a donut
when they get fat it's just like BL BL
BL you know uh exceptions don't make the
rule and 70% of us are overweight in
this country we do not need any
encouragement to be chubby so Ralph says
I think it depends on the culture and
the time period think about Paul Ruben
and his paintings in the bar boric era
um I'm sorry nobody there ain't no
paintings that have lizo on it you know
we we could say that maybe different
body types are a little bit you know
there's different preferences at the
time you know like there was a whole
wave of the big booty thing and then
there was the super skinny chicks in the
early 2000s but generally it it's thin
it's thin maybe um a little bit athletic
at some points but it's skinny guys
aren't
they're not they're not looking for guts
so I also tweeted men don't generally
like for wives now again there's
the adom 22 Exceptions there is
the I don't know uh I guess the Logan
Paul exceptions but this isn't the rule
and the problem is we keep looking at
women that are exceptionally hot that
get away with things so um an average
chick would never be able to get away
with the level of promiscuity that Nina
Agdal and Lena did um especially if it
was public you know and I again I I
think cuz sometimes girls will say oh
but this chick you know was able to pull
that guy and she was a and my
answer is she's hotter than you yeah the
top 10 20% of women get exceptional
outcomes um a lot I see a lot wasted
anyway you know um and the other issue
is once you've had five Partners as a
chick um you your chance of a happy
marriage drops to 20
30% and E this is the problem even if
you escape even if if some simp bails
you out of your bad decision the truth
of the matter is the person that it
hurts the most really is ourselves
because promiscuity uh basically means
that your your chance of a happy
marriage is very slim um you know if you
were going to take a pill and that pill
you had a 80% chance of dying a 70%
chance of dying you probably wouldn't
take that pill but it's interesting
because women will take the promiscuity
pill for over a decade and then wonder
why they're in the situation that
they're in you know so what was what was
the first comment on this on this post
Ask Logan Paul that question yes um well
again the exceptions don't break this to
Logan Paul are these really the
responses
guys wow Logan Paul is an
except we know guys why do we always
have to argue the
exception um so then they did a poll um
cuz I had another tweet I said men
prefer debt-free virgins without
tattoos yes yes now is this crazy men
don't want to have to pay off your debt
men don't really want to see you Inked
Up you know that is the one thing I am
so happy my mom pushed on me she would
always tell me don't get a tattoo always
always always and and I when I was
younger I would be like Mom you're so
judged mental why are you so judgmental
and now I say thank you mother I have
zero tattoos and I am I'm very proud of
it because I keep seeing all these uh
beautiful chicks ruining their beauty
with ink a and you
know it's not to say there aren't men
that will accept it but by and large men
don't like that sort of thing so they
they did a poll um Jason Holmes men I'm
men do you prefer debt-free virgins
without tattoos I'm trying to see how
accurate girl is in her statements uh
70% said yes 16% said I don't mind and
14% said I'm not accurate so 16% said I
don't mind 70% said I'm right on the
money and and this kind of you know goes
into society because it's like what the
bottom 30% of men are they really going
to be that picky and you have to
understand that men will accept things
because they have to not because they
want to and you saw that with Adam 22
where initially when the thought of his
girl with another dude he he didn't like
it but then eventually you know enough
conditioning um me they really turned
men into women so so uh Brittan Brittan
brtan so brtan really came in and said
wow thank you Pearl for explaining to us
how men think that's you know she just
was so considerate and understanding and
really said I understand wrong she said
I prefer men with eight figure bank
accounts doesn't mean they're going to
talk to me well you know um I think I'm
going to disagree with you here because
one honestly isn't that hard to do you
know um I I would say it is
exceptionally hard and damn near
impossible for a man to become a
multi-millionaire most men just aren't
going to do it um however to become a
debt-free
Virgin uh we all start that way let
everyone starts that way now most women
ruin it right but everybody starts as a
debt-free virgin with no
tattoos um so in one instance everyone
becomes that and in another in instance
barely anybody becomes it um so now PMA
says her marketing is for petophile and
you'll see this whenever women want to
shame men um for liking younger women I
did not say under age women I said
younger women um what they'll do is
they'll try to shame him for it and it's
a way for older women to compete so
she's going to say you know um that
she's going to imply that basically an
adult can't be a virgin uh why can't a
22-year-old chick be a virgin well it's
our poor decisions and poor choices yet
they will continue to blame it on the
men so um chadus is or cha Doula guys
you got to stop with the the names like
what what is this the debt part isn't a
deal breaker as long as it's not out of
control and I 100% agree with this
because I I I used to do Street
interviews and I would ask guys um would
you rather have a woman that has 50
bodies or $50,000 in debt that you'd
have to pay off and most of the guys
said they'd pick the debt even even guys
that didn't make that much money they're
like you know what I'll pay off her debt
I am not I am not doing the bodies so uh
so what does that inherently show that
we have value from birth we are born
with value where men have to create
their value men have to become the
things that women want where women are
just born the things that men want and
it's our job not to destroy it and the
problem is is older women fat
chicks will lie to younger women about
what men want and it makes it very
confusing for the next generation of
women when you see women like Kim
Kardashian and cardi be rewarded for
their decisions you know it's actually a
very logical path that women women take
you know when Kim Kardashian becomes a
billionaire off of a sex tape I I could
see the draw why a lot of chicks would
want to do that